Good afternoon, everybody,
and welcome to this major symposium on human cancer models.
It's my privilege to chair this session at the 2026
ACR
annual meeting.
So precision oncology
has fundamentally changed
how we classify cancer.
Through genomic and molecular profiling,
we can now identify actionable alterations
with unprecedented resolution,
and yet a critical gap remains.
Tumors with similar genomic profiles often behave very
differently in patients.
They respond differently to therapy.
They evolve
under therapy
and under therapy pressures. And so they develop resistance
through mechanisms that still we probably don't fully
understand,
and that are not always predictable with genome sequencing
alone.
So this session actually is designed to
discuss the translational relevance of human tumor
systems, bridging discovery and validation with their
clinical implementation to advance
human cancer treatment.
This symposium
is built around a simple but consequential
premise.
To truly personalize cancer therapy, we must move
beyond inference and toward direct measurements
of therapeutic response in human tumor models.
In other words, we must not only
understand and ask what the tumor is,
but what the tumor does when challenged with therapy.
This shift from a descriptive to functional
oncology represent a critical evolution
in the diagnostic and treatment fields.
Today's session is structured to reflect just this
and this continuum.
We will begin with Dr. David Tuveson,
whose pioneering work in organoid models
has advanced our ability to recapitulate tumor biology in solid
cancer, such as
pancreatic cancer.
We will then hear from Jeffrey Tyner, Dr.
Jeffrey Tyner, who will present on ex vivo functional testing
approaches
in leukemia.
So we'll shift from solid tumors to liquid
tumors, demonstrating how these models can directly inform
therapeutic strategies. And finally, I will conclude with a
perspective on functional precision oncology platform
that is being translated into clinical decision-making
using live patient tumor cells.
Session goals are highlighting cutting-edge human tumor models,
compare platforms
and applications, discuss their potential integration into clinical
workflows, and identify future direction,
hopefully.
As you listen to this presentation, please,
I will encourage you, the audience, to consider a few key
questions that we have in mind and that will guide
our discussion. What defines a truly predictive human cancer
model?
Where does genomic prediction fall short,
and why?
Can functional testing capture clinically relevant
heterogeneity,
including resistant subpopulations?
And critically, what level of evidence do we need
and is required to bring these approaches into routine clinical
practice?
The format is three speakers with 20 minutes each.
Discussion after each talk is five minutes, and then we'll have a final panel
discussion of 10 minutes.
Dr. Tuveson will need to leave early today because he is
engaged before the end of this session in another
session here at the ACR. And for this reason, I encourage the
audience to ask all the questions you guys want to ask to him
directly in those five minutes, and later on you can email him.
With that, it's my pleasure to introduce our first speaker.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. David Tuveson.
Thank you. Thank you,
David.
Thanks so much, Pierpaolo. That was very kind. Hello, everyone.
We have about 20 seats, so you can get your
standing calisthenics or you can sit down, but there's like 20 seats easily up
here.
So we've had this theme
for about a decade to a decade and a half, and I've never seen this many people at
an ACR conference interested in it.
So it's great to see.
The concept in the past is if you could build the model, it could be the
avatar for your patient. It would be the bacteriology test.
So you could multiplex your questions ex vivo, and then the doc
could go in and actually go with the therapy that looks the best.
That was the idea 15 years ago.
I'll show you where we are in pancreas with that.
So this slide has some photos. This is Amber,
where my arrow is, and this is Granya.
They were a pair on putting together a pancreas cancer trial looking at cytotoxic
drugs in the era before the RAS drugs.
So this started in 2018. And on the right are
the same team with Jen Knox, who was the PI of the trial,
Fayyaz Noota, who's a terrific quantitative biologist at
Toronto, and Ken YiuAt
Memorial, as well as Stephanie Ramotar.
So I'm going to talk about an actual clinical trial we did with these models.
This is my disclosure slide, which sadly is not going to be relevant for my talk.
What's the hypothesis? I already told you.
The hypothesis, this could be a bacteriology test.
If you could stratify your patients with bad pancreas cancer,
advanced, so a surgeon couldn't cut it out, would you help them?
And this is, again, a question just using the cytotoxic regimens.
There's two that are approved worldwide.
And so the approach, again, was to develop the organoid models with a close
collaboration and partnership with Hans Clevers from
the Netherlands. You've all heard of him, and he was very generous and
sent his senior scientists over to Cold Spring in
2012 so that we could learn
the Dutch methods, and then we innovated on it as
Americans do, and developed ways to make
organoids from mouse models and human specimens.
And in the end of the day, the organoids were useful.
They could model health, wild type cells,
every stage of neoplasia, so early pre-invasive cancer, invasive
cancer metastasis
from the animal as well as from the human.
And when you did the comparisons at the omics level,
what you saw in the organoid was what you saw in the specimen.
And so it looked good, like you could use it as a discovery
platform and possibly as a therapeutic and diagnostic platform.
So we decided to go
into following our patients with such a method.
This is a six-well dish
with a human's hand holding it, and these little
spots here are little drops of a extracellular matrix
substrate. The common one we use is the commercial product known as Matrigel, but
we've tested all kinds of them. And most of them
work. They just vary in how you use them,
the conditions,
cost, et cetera. But lots of things will work.
And again, this is just a cartoon, of course, of what an organoid looks like, a
single cell layer in a cystic structure.
And on the right are just some light field pictures of what you would
see when they grow. It's always very exciting for people the first time they do it.
It's kind of like a pet rock.
So we use the organoids to ask questions about patients.
So of course, we used it for discovery stuff in the mouse models, all of that.
But in the human, we were asking, would the organoids tell us something that
looked real, like it was occurring in the human?
And so
on the lower left, you see
some therapeutic
curves, some IC50 curves,
where we were testing a variety of human-derived pancreas
cancer organoids with gemcitabine, which is a monotherapeutic
chemotherapy drug, which has been approved for several decades for pancreas.
What I want you to appreciate is these curves are pretty tight.
So there's about a tenfold window across dozens of
samples. So the therapeutic index, if you were to compare a sensitive to a
resistant patient, is pretty narrow.
And here it's shown in tertiles where the most sensitive are on the bottom in
blue and the most resistant in red.
And we ask just very simple-minded questions with this data,
like if the organoid showed sensitivity to these
drugs, did the patient actually do well when they were treated?
Anecdotally, it looked actually quite promising.
We asked another question, which is, could you take super sensitive organoids
and find transcriptional signatures that then you can apply to human samples
and ask, could you stratify the patients?
And such an approach is shown here, where in this case, patients that received
FOLFIRINOX, a three-chemo drug regimen,
we looked for an oxaliplatin signature.
And in this case, if you had the signature, you were in blue, and you see basically
more blue going down in this waterfall plot compared to the ones on the
right. If you looked at overall survival, it wasn't
that impressive. But again, this is a bad disease where people don't do well,
and the drugs are helpful but not amazing.
But this was the data that we had early on.
And so it begged the question, could we get past this anecdotal
retrospective approach and learn something on a bigger stage?
And so with that in mind, we were able to start a collaboration with the University
of Toronto. Stephen Gallinger is a surgeon there who had
really amassed a large number of patient specimens where the molecular
details of the patients were known following surgery by laser
capture of the neoplastic cells.
And Stephen and Jen Knox, who was the head medical oncologist there, was willing to
collaborate across the northern border for us to put together
a very large clinical study with four sites in the States.
And the sites in the States were Hopkins, where Liz Jaffee was the co-PI with Jen
on the trial, the Farber, where Brian Wolpin was the PI,
Memorial, Ken Yu,
and a very large healthcare system that we were able to work with at Long Island,
Northwell Health, where Dan King was the PI.
And so this very large collection of sites came
together to do a randomized clinical trial comparing the two
accepted cares for pancreas cancer, which were gemcitabine
plus nab-paclitaxel, trade name Abraxane, with
FOLFIRINOX, which is a three-chemo regimen.
Randomized A versus B. We get the tissue to make organoids, and there's all kinds
of other translational science. So this is what the trial looked
like. Over 200 patients were
screened. In the end, 160 were randomized, 80 assigned to each
arm.
When you do trials like this, when you have really sick patients, you lose patients
because they unfortunately, the disease gallops through very
rapidly. But in the end, we had 71 on the FOLFIRINOX arm and 69 on
the gem/nab-paclitaxel arm.
And again, it was a clinical study.
They were comparing these two regimens.And we were doing the
correlative science. And so this was the cohort demographics, because how
medics present their trials, like when you do a randomized trial, are
they truly random, the populations, in terms of gender,
amount of disease, their ECOG performance status, meaning how healthy or sick
are they? What is their ethnicity and ancestry?
And what was the final diagnosis? Was it adenocarcinoma versus
other things?
There's a blood biomarker in pancreas, which is a glycan called CA19-9.
And then, of course, metastatic burden, RAS mutational status,
et cetera.
More or less, they were pretty well-matched, although there were some
caveats shown here.
These were patients, again, never treated, no operations, no other treatment
beforehand. So this was the clinical result, and the clinical result was
interesting to those of us who are pancreas cancer med-oncs, in that
the gemcitabine plus the fancy Taxol did better than the three-drug
regimen, which was developed by our colleagues in France and was thought to be the
"more active, more strong approach."
And so that wasn't the case in a randomized trial in overall survival.
And if you looked at the subtypes of pancreas, as is true of
every cancer, there are differences of the cancer.
Pierpaolo talked about heterogeneity.
So there are heterogeneity across patients as well as within a patient.
And so heterogeneity across patients in pancreas, there's classical and there's
basal.
And that's a
simplification, and I'll talk about that in a bit, too.
But essentially, the patients with basal, which is more mesenchymal, did worse,
particularly when they got FOLFIRINOX, and the patients with classical, when they
got gem plus the Taxol, did better.
And this was, again, a different way to look at that same data.
And so the blood biomarker that physicians use in their clinic is this
glycan I talked about. It's actually a pretty fascinating molecule, and
if it tails down fast within a few weeks, the patient's going to do
well. If it does the opposite, patient's not going to do well.
That's sort of a clinical observation in the past, and this study really confirmed
that. For those patients where it tailed down, they were in blue, they actually
lived quite a bit longer than those where it didn't tail.
And if it went the opposite way, they did poorly.
So again, it just was consistent, almost a positive control
for our trial. So again, back to the science.
The science was we got a tumor, and it was biopsied
so that we could do the studies. These were patients with measurable disease,
and the biopsies we received were 18-gauge needle biopsies.
And most often, say, 70% plus were liver
mets in these patients.
And they would get up to six cores, and they would go
for organoid development, sequencing, both at the DNA and RNA
level, looking for biomarkers of subtypes, in this case,
GATA6, and doing really fancy
spatial approaches, mostly protein-based, which were
done at Johns Hopkins in Liz's shop, called CODEX, which tells us about immune
infiltrates, fibroblast subtypes, et cetera.
We also had an interest in circulating biomarkers.
I talked about the glycan, but of course, if we could develop other biomarkers,
that could be quite useful. And again, the questions that were asked were kind of
self-evident.
With the first one, very importantly,
did the profile that we found in the organoid and the patient match, meaning
sequence of the DNA and RNA? Because I claimed on our paper 10 years
ago, that's what we found in a limited series.
Point number two, though, is really apropos to this whole session.
Does the chemosensitivity, the sensitivity of the organoids,
match how the patient did? Because if it did, then you would have a looking
glass into the disease. You would have your bacteriology
test. And then there's all this associated stuff like
finding biomarkers of that. Predictive biomarkers of response and resistance is
really what we need because then we know how to measure things and plan
the best studies.
And all of us are excited to know is if
patients are great responders, it may not be cell autonomous, there may be tumor
extrinsic factors, immune cells, the fibroblasts, et cetera.
And then, of course, this sort of open question about finding
anything that wouldn't need a biopsy of solid tissue to determine what's
going on.
So here's the data.
And so we received 186 biopsies from Canada and the
US from a total of 183 patients.
Seventy-three percent were biopsies from the met in the pancreas,
10 from primary biopsies in the pancreas,
and then there's assorted other things from either mets to the peritoneum, node,
occasionally to the lung, and we actually did have one or two patients where they
had brain mets, which is not a super common presentation, obviously, for pancreas,
at least with today's medicines.
And let me show you what really we learned from this, and this is
really illuminating to us. We're not so bad at making these organoids
from pancreas cancer. We've probably made, I don't know, 500 over the last
15 years, and a bunch of them are submitted to the ATCC
repository
for those of you looking for sources of organoids.
We were batting about 50%. So if you were a baseball player, you would be the
most valuable player. But if you're trying to develop a medical test, you don't
like that. You want to be 80%, 90%. And so
that's something we keep studying.
But we were able to make good number, but we fail a lot.
And we take that really seriously.
And so when I get these studies of places of people who claim all this
stuff and they don't actually look carefully at what they've generated, it really
gets me irritated.
And I hope none of you in the audience are those people.
So of the ones that failed, we learned a lot here because when they failed, they
could still make a culture, but we can't find mutations.
So it's obviously wild-type growth, and these could be cholangiocytes that
take on a cystic quality.And we call these pseudo
normal cultures. Or they could have started to
take as an organoid and then petered out. We couldn't passage them.
Sometimes we get these biopsies and actually it was just fibrosis or necrosis and
there was nothing alive, and so you can't blame biology for that.
It's just sort of the luck of the draw for your biopsy.
And occasionally there was contamination with microbes, but pretty rarely
because we really developed some good SOPs.
But we've actually studied this failure stuff for a while, and it's cool, and I
don't really have a lot of time to go into it, but in the failure space, we do have
wild type P53 patients,
and they don't generate organoids well.
And it doesn't take rocket science cancer biologist to figure that one out.
There are other molecular features that we're finding now.
The reason we're chasing it is we want to improve the cultures so that we're not
50%. We want to be 80%.
But this is where we are now. And again, the way we make our organoids is kind of
rigid. They have to survive multiple passages to the point where we can do
the omics and do all the-- including the pharmacotyping et cetera.
There are these fast ways that I'll describe a little bit at the end, but this is
something that
we have noticed. And so one of the big things for us is, are you RAS mutant?
So in pancreas, 90, 92% have a RAS mutation,
KRAS mutation.
You'll have some wild type pancreas cancers, but again, it's a minority.
And so having that RAS mutation where your mutant allele
frequency is 45% or above, that's kind of the entry
criteria.
And if you're less, then you're in this purgatory category
where you have to find out are you real or not.
And two, actually, we call these flagged.
And if you're flagged, then we do all kinds of things to see if you are a
mutant, and we'll put in nutan, which will kill you if you have a wild
type B53. We'll take out the growth factors or poison the
canonical ERB family members. And that actually can help
enrich.
But occasionally we get these wild types.
And the wild types are interesting because they have drivers that are different,
and the drivers frequently, they're drugs that the docs can use in the clinic.
And then down here, you'll also have the quote, "pseudo normals" that aren't
malignant because they don't have any aneuploidy when you do copy number
alterations.
But this is an approach, it wasn't an invention, but we kind of perfected it to the
point where we believed it. And what'd we
learn? So this is actually quite interesting.
One of the best drugs would be if the patient's organoid didn't grow.
So if you failed to make the organoid, those patients lived double
than the patients where you didn't make the organoid.
So really the organoid was a predictor that the patient's not going to do well.
So if you made an organoid, that was a more malignant cancer.
Again, getting back to this point that the less malignant cultures need
more care and consideration, more science around what we need
to do to keep them going.
So what about the other part of the science?
So here's just a cartoon of we get the liver biopsy and we want to do all these
things I described, and here's some pictures of all those things, high throughput
drug screening and
et cetera. In the end of the day, it took us 70
days in median to get the culture and test the drugs.
But we had a third of them that we could do it in faster, less than 60 days.
And
so that was really a finding. And we were asking this question about signatures.
There's two kinds of signatures, the empiric one, the area under the curve.
If you're sensitive in the organoid, are you sensitive in the clinic?
The second is a transcriptional signature I mentioned before, where you take the
hypersensitive organoids and the hyperresistant organoids
to find differentially expressed genes and then apply it to the patient population.
And we used both. And it turned out the AUC was okay.
That could actually distinguish if you're sensitive in the organoid, you're
sensitive in the patient. But a more robust one was definitely the transcriptional
signature. And this was great because if you had a transcriptional signature, you
wouldn't need the organoid in the first place.
And so if you had the signature on all the patients, the more sensitive
signatures, you did better, particularly those getting gemcitabine plus
nab-paclitaxel.
So that was the study, and we still have some more science that we're doing.
It's not been submitted yet for publication.
What about the fancy new drugs? So here's one, the RAS drugs.
And so this is actually the pan RAS drug.
It's very related, in fact, the same molecule chemically to the one that Revolution
Medicine has great data that they've started to
discuss in their randomized Phase III trial.
Well, in blue here, in baby blue, these are wild type RAS mutant
pancreas cancer organoids. And look, some of them are totally resistant to this
drug, and it's very heterogeneous, but one is really sensitive.
So the baby blue is all over the place.
The ones that are mutant for aspartate valine, arginine are tighter.
But we looked at all of our organoids for signatures of RAS, and this is a
transcriptional signature.
And about half of them have a RAS signature and half don't.
So even in our organoid cultures, the RNA they have, not all of them have a RAS
dependency score. And in the wild types, I mean, only one out of the six here had
a RAS dependency score. Maybe that's that one right
here. And then the last thing are some other innovations.
And so the more rapid way is not to measure ATP levels, but
use microscopy. So this is high content
imaging. And we're using a dye on the outside of the organoid to see it.
And we can do that in less than 30 days.
And that looks actually quite promising.
And so far the correlation coefficient between doing it this way versus the
ATP is very good.
And then finally,
what about that microenvironment?
So the microenvironment in pancreas is fibroblasts and macrophages.
Very little blood vessels.
We have actually developed a method to include the fibroblasts.
Here's the dye-based method where the fibroblasts are in red, the organoids are in
green. And we'd ask the same kind of question using this method.
And here's the H&E, and here's a stain of the fibroblasts from GFP staining.
Gemcitabine takes 50% more gemcitabine to
killThe cancer cells, when you have the fibroblast, takes three times
more of the RAS drug to kill them.
So this is interesting to us. Taxol could care less. So it's impervious to Taxol.
But very interestingly, certain drugs
look like are affected by that microenvironment.
So the summary, before I do the thanks, is shown here.
We've done a co-clinical trial. The clinical trial was published and now the
translational work is being written up.
Our time to availability of the culture
is still 70 days. The median is too long.
The fraction of organoids we can generate is less than we want,
50%. The major issue is that the patients with the better outcomes, we
can't make the organoids. So when we start to do all this stuff in vitro, we're
really studying that more resistant population to start with.
Obviously, the results would be so much better if we could get all the organoids,
because the sensitive ones would be, we would think, more
sensitive in vitro too.
But we're
doing research to understand the failures, and we're changing the culture
conditions and doing high content microscopy as I showed you.
The co-cultures are looking pretty interesting.
And now we're going to add in the macrophages.
Targeted agents and resistance to them, studying that may be enabled with these
culture systems. And this is really an example of what Pierpaolo was alluding
to, the new approaches and methods, which is why half of you are in this audience,
I suspect.
And at Cold Spring Harbor, we're not a company, we're a think tank,
and we are hiring the next wave of organoid scientists if you think you can fix
this problem or at least the various ones I delineated.
This is a picture of everyone who did the work.
In bold are the people who did most work, and really, Amber is the one who drove
this trial. And this is her team.
And they've all gone on to better and brighter careers.
And I thank you for your attention.
So
for the questions, please first identify yourself and then ask the question.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. This is Reza from Clinical Immunology, San Diego.
I just wrote it here for myself. Given the modest overall
survival benefit of the GNP and only 48%
malignant PDO establishment rate, how confident
are you that early PDO-based drug sensitivity, including the
RAS inhibitors, will change individual patient
management beyond what we already infer from the
CA19-9 dynamics at the four weeks?
And what prospective evidence do you have that acting on
PDO results actually improves the PFS OS
rather than just correlating with them?
So again, I think it's very important that you and everyone here understand that
the first thing you need to do is a co-clinical trial to gather enough
data so that you can propose to do a prospective trial, which would
actually address exactly what you're talking about.
So we can't use these models until we have an
investigational new device type application that goes to a state to
approve it, and then you can do a test, such as the one
you're describing. The intention, though, is to address
specifically your point.
We had to start this way, but we fully
intend to do so. Again, the CA19-9 dips
or spikes are terrific, and
we are actually actively trying to correlate, would the
organoid have predicted this failure too? So far, the failure looks good.
But again, because we couldn't get the hypersensitive organoids to grow, it's
harder for us to do the dip. We're going to have to take this one offline because
this is not a simple question. This is more like a discussion point.
But you can easily contact me, and I'd be happy to do so.
Thank you.
We've got at least two more people that I can fit in. You decide, Pierpaolo.
Frank Li from which AppTek. Very interesting talk.
Zong Liu from MD Anderson Cancer.
You got to fix your audio.
All right. So my question is, how do you do the quality
control? So when you get the biopsy, say, in the first place, because now look
like a 50% success rate. So what is step you
did, like a quality con-
So the first sample goes for pathological verification.
So what happens is the interventional radiologist or the surgeon are going
biopsy. Okay? And these biopsies are going
to the pathology. Unless they read out as adenocarcinoma of the pancreas, we never
get engaged in the whole trial.
But it is possible. If you know, when you look at a pancreas
specimen, you'll have an area that's very necrotic, an area that's just fibrotic,
and
it is always possible that you're going to get a piece to make an organoid from
that the pathologist would never say there's any cancer. So that is correct.
That is correct that that's an issue.
Okay. All right.
Yep.
Thank you for your awesome presentation.
I have a quick question about your co-culturing with the CAF.
So when you co-culture with the CAF, so CAF come from the same patient, or
you can use your different type of CAF from the other?
Yeah, great question. So the data I showed you was not the CAF from
that patient with the organoid. We had to get the CAF and engineer it to express a
fluorescent protein, all the rest of it.
One could imagine doing that. And of course, the easiest thing would be to
get tumor fragments and not even do organoids at all, or tissue slices.
And again, there's just not going to be enough tissue available from
enough patients to do those type of studies.
We're going to have to think of additional methods that would
enable us to dig into it. But anyway, it's a good question.
We'll try-
We have a couple of minutes. Be brief, please.
Yeah. So my question, very simple.
You transferring CAF data is quite interesting.
So even the PDO field, right? You still
have the specimen. Can you do reverse
analysis to see the signature match
PDO field?
It's a good question.
I don't think that we have done that yet, although we have discussed
thatBecause you're right, you could just skip the
ex vivo totally, try to develop your biomarkers
from the patient.
Yes.
From the patient samples.
If you had a high enough quality RNA that you get from laser caption
from the tumor, from enough patients that were sensitive and resistant, that should
be a possible approach. And we've discussed it, but we haven't performed
that yet. It's a good question.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I'm working on the hepatocellular carcinoma
organoid, and then
as it's known that the organoid growing from the liver is
most slow growing and rarely barely growing comparing to the other organ
such as a colon. So for your specific project,
did you see that those that was failed from growing the organoid is
mostly from the liver metastasis comparing to the other metastasis organ?
And then,
do you think that low failure organoid group is just a miss of
the patient group, that if we just neglect it, it's going to be just like
skipping one group of the patient that we're studying in the project?
So, this will be the last question I take.
We
found that we were pretty successful actually growing from the liver
mets.
The point you're raising about hepatocellular carcinoma
notwithstanding, where it is more challenging for you and folks in your
field to
develop those ex vivo methods that will allow you to expand.
We did have trouble growing from peritoneal metastases,
I would say if you think of one site that was hard, and we
don't fully understand that, but again, the cell types that are present in the
microenvironment and the peritoneal mets are a little different than in the
pancreas primary or the liver. So we're trying to add back the cells that
exist in the peritoneal mets now.
I would suggest that you keep pushing on developing your
better methods. So for hepatocellular, I suspect it will work out.
Okay?
Thank you, David.
And
if any other person has questions, please email him
directly. Thank you. Thank you, David.
Please welcome Dr. Tyner,
who is going to talk about ex vivo functional testing to support
development of new therapeutic regimens in leukemia.
Thank you very much, Dr. Claudio, for the nice invitation, for organizing this
workshop. I would echo what both Dr.
Claudio and Touveson have said that I'm really delighted to see this great turnout
here. I've been at other sessions of this type before, never seen such
enthusiasm, so thank you all for being here as well.
These are my disclosures, also not relevant here today.
All right. So I want to begin with turning the clock back 20
years, which is the point in time which I joined the cancer research field.
And at that point in time, there was, I think everyone here probably remembers, a
great deal of enthusiasm, that we were right on the
precipice of solving this whole thing based on enthusiasm about
targeted therapies and next generation sequencing.
And there was an idea, a concept that we were going to be able to take a tumor,
sequence its genome, and prescribe effective treatment options.
And to be sure, this was powered by some really astounding
work, ABL inhibitors in CML.
My mentor, Dr. Druker's work, obviously a terrific
example of how this genetically, genomically guided therapy can
work. And it's certainly not the only example.
I quickly brainstormed and thought of a number of other genetic targets for
which therapies have been designed and have been successful, maybe not all quite
the home runs that ABL inhibitors were in CML, but certainly providing clinical
benefit.
However, I think we all know that the promise of genetically
guided therapy has had some challenges as well.
Many targets have been discovered that are not drugged, will never be drugged
because they're loss of function.
We know now that there's a great deal of heterogeneity and tumors don't
just have a single driver, they have lots of them in many cases.
And the genetics tells us very little about issues such as cell
state, immune suppression, and the tumor microenvironment.
And so as a result, while there certainly has been
success of genetically guided therapy,
all too often those have been
rarer than we would like. There's been only minorities of patients that have been
matched with therapies, and generally speaking, response rates have been low.
So we're all here today to talk about an alternative, to supplement
genetic guided therapy, a functional approach.
Well, ASCO would tell us not so fast.
There's a series of white papers that came out over the last 15,
20 years, that have really challenged the concept of
functional precision medicine.
And the overall conclusion is that these
tests are not clinically validated, not ready for prime time.
It's worth noting that these white papers are all based on older work.
If you look at the dates of these papers, they're mostly in the '80s, the '90s, a
few in the early 2000s.
And I don't want to ding this work. This work was done with the technologies that
were the best available at that time.
But technologies advance. We now have newer approaches.
We have better ability to evaluate the organoids or
other models that are growing in ex vivo.
And I think evaluating this field of functional precision medicine based on
this work would be equivalent to evaluating genetic therapy based on
Sanger sequencing of just a handful of genes.
Technologies do advance, and just over the last five-ish years,
there's been tremendous work by many people around the
world,
some of which we're hearing about in this session, who are running prospective
trials and showing, demonstrating, that there is clinical benefit of
these functional tests.These are all functional trials that have been run.
There's many case reports that have been published as well.
So I'll spend the next 15 minutes or so telling you about some of the work that
we've been doing in this area at OHSU, Oregon Health Science University.
We've been at this for a long time, almost the last 20 years, when I started my
postdoc and began to develop these types of ex vivo tests that have evolved
over the years. They've evolved from genetic
approaches such as siRNAs to panels of small molecules.
They've evolved from plate-based, high throughput plate-based
readouts to flow-based, imaging-based.
And as I'll talk at the end, we're now exploring single-cell-based readouts,
single-cell sequencing-based readouts.
We have developed large cohorts, which I'll describe, of heme
malignancy, mostly AML patients, for which we have done this ex vivo
testing, and we've paired it with omics, with DNA, RNA sequencing, proteomics,
et cetera.
And through which we're able to integrate all of these data and model
pathways and mechanisms of response and resistance to drugs and drug
combinations, which I'll describe a little bit.
Early on, we had some success that demonstrated clinical validity of
the approach. About 13 years ago, we published a paper in New England Journal,
where we demonstrated that chronic neutrophilic leukemia had a targetable
mutation in CSF3 receptor, which is targetable with JAK
inhibitors. This led to collection of a large cohort of
CNL, from which we conducted a lot of omic studies and mechanistic
studies, as well as a clinical trial demonstrating benefit of JAK
inhibitors for CNL, which is now considered one of the standards of care for this
disease,
as well as evaluation of resistance.
All of this was driven by ex vivo testing of a single CNL
patient specimen that showed that JAK inhibitor sensitivity.
And so it was this and other examples like it that led to one of the major programs
that I spent the better part of the last decade of my life working on, which
was the BEAT-AML program.
This was a preclinical effort. This is the 1.0 program, not the 2.0
master trial.
The 1.0 effort, where we endeavored to collect almost 1,000 AML patient
specimens, conduct these ex vivo drug sensitivity studies,
sequence RNA and DNA. A separate series of studies looked at the
immune microenvironment, which I won't have time to talk about.
And then integrate all of these data to, again, predict mechanisms and
biomarkers of drug response and resistance.
These data have been published in "Nature" in 2018 and in
"Cancer Cell" in 2022. And the original conception of this
study was actually fairly simplistic.
It was going back to that idea of genetically guided therapy.
Can we match drug response with mutations?
Can we find mutations that predict for response to any of our targeted agents?
And the answer is yes, absolutely.
This is an image from that 2018 paper showing that there are a plethora
of sensitivities on the left in red and resistances on the
right in blue of mutations that correlate with drug
response or resistance. And that's all been interesting, and there's a lot of
good information there that we have been following up on, I think need to be
followed up on. But one of the things that I'm really excited about is that
although this was our initial concept,
the data really pointed us towards other areas that I think are even more
important in explaining drug response.
And I won't be able to get into all the different ways that the data set have been
used, most of which go far beyond that original concept of mutations and drug
response. I'm really going to focus on one finding, which is
that the tumor cell state, essentially the differentiation state of
these AML tumor cells, is one of the
strongest predictors or drivers of response and
resistance to various therapies.
And this was derived from some single-cell sequencing work that was done
out of Dana-Farber in a "Cell" paper in 2019, in which they were
able to assign six discrete cell states in which AML tumors
can exist. Some very stem-like, HSC progenitor-like,
others more differentiated, monocyte, dendritic cell-like.
We're able to use the gene expression signatures from these six
different cell states to deconvolute our bulk RNA seq and understand for
all of these 900 AML tumor cases, how stem-like
are they, how committed are they, and how does that correlate with the drug
response? And the answer is it correlates profoundly.
This is a heat map showing that of the 120-ish drugs that we
studied, 73 of them are strongly
governed by the differentiation state in which the tumors are arrested.
As an example of this, in the very middle of the heat map is the BCL2 inhibitor
venetoclax. This is currently probably the most commonly used frontline
therapy for AML right now.
Venetoclax works very well in tumors that are more stem-like, more progenitor-like.
It has liabilities when the tumors become more differentiated.
This was our observation. Others made this observation around the same time from ex
vivo testing. This has now been clinically validated.
There are large cohorts, clinical cohorts, that absolutely demonstrate that
monocytic differentiation state is one of the prominent resistance mechanisms
for venetoclax-based therapies.
On the inverse of venetoclax is the HDAC
inhibitor panobinostat. Panobinostat shows the opposite pattern.
It's very good against those more differentiated tumors, very lousy against the
stem-like tumors. And we have a whole cluster of drugs on the right that are kind
of venetoclax-like, some on the left that are more panobinostat-like, and then some
in the middle that are interesting.
They're pretty good against the extremes and have some liabilities in those more
intermediate stages of differentiation.
So based on this work, we can now begin to assign a
drug response, not just based on genetics, but also based on cell state.
And so we can go back a little bit in time.
AMLs used to be diagnosed based on the French-American-British
system of M0 to M7, which aligned roughly with the
differentiation state of the tumors.
Perhaps we should revisit this concept or use a more nuanced version of it, because
based on all these ex vivo data, we can assign not just venetoclax, but
most of the drug classes that are currently being studied and been being used
clinically into whether they work better against these more primitive or
more committed tumors. And I've just annotated some of those major drug families
and where they fit into this picture.So
perhaps we should now think about drug combinations that bridge across these
different tumor cell differentiation states.
And we've studied that very question in a series of papers shown here.
I'll just briefly summarize the findings of this work, where we've
taken a subset of the BEAT-AML cohort, over
400 of those patient samples, treated them with a series of drug
combinations. In this case, they all included that BCL-2 inhibitor venetoclax
paired with about 25 other agents.
We collected clinical data, flow-based
immunophenotyping data, molecular data, et cetera.
And the frontline therapy, the venetoclax paired with hypomethylating
agents, was one of the agents we studied, and as we show in that paper, the
response patterns ex vivo match very closely with
those that are observed clinically.
So the ven/aza looks like it matches well with what happens clinically.
What about these other novel venetoclax-based combinations?
On this plot, the horizontal is the overall activity of the combination, the
vertical is the synergy. So those combinations that are more towards the origin on
the lower left are those that are both more active and synergistic.
We have a handful of drugs or combinations that look similar to the approved
ven/aza, maybe a little worse, but an awful lot that look a lot
better. So these data would predict that there are
a large number of novel venetoclax-based combinations that could be
outperforming the current frontline therapy that's used in AML.
There's a lot of interesting
nuggets to go after in this data set.
I'm not going to have time to show you very much of it.
I'll just show one that we've worked up substantially, venetoclax paired with the
CDK4/6 inhibitor palbociclib, which turned out to be one of the most active
and synergistic combinations that we tested.
We validated this in multiple PDX models.
This is all published in a recent Cell Reports Medicine paper.
And also in that paper, we took a deeper dive into the patient sample data to try
to understand why is it that this venetoclax paired with CDK4/6
inhibitors is better than either single agent alone.
We were able to come up with some markers as to which patient populations would
benefit from this, and these include patients with RAS mutations or some of those
monocyte-like cell state features.
So remember that venetoclax is better against the more stem-like, but when you pair
it with CDK4/6, all of a sudden you have activity in that resistant
subset that are more differentiated.
The other interesting thing shown on the right is when we looked at gene expression
patterns in samples that were exhibiting synergy versus those that were
already sensitive to the single agent venetoclax, we observed that almost all
of the pathways that came up were pathways involved in protein synthesis.
I won't have time to show you all the data, but we were able to come up with a
model and validate this model that illustrates why venetoclax might
be working in the primitive setting and not working in the more monocytic setting,
and why this combination is rescuing those monocytic-like tumors,
which involves an
attempt by these AML cells to
upregulate protein synthesis when they're exposed to venetoclax.
In primitive cells, the synthesis rate is already at a high level, cannot be
upregulated, and so those tumors are sensitive to venetoclax.
In the more differentiated...
And
the group in Finland who conducted the fabulous VINEX trial,
a trial that prospectively tested venetoclax ex vivo in
patients who were then treated and showed that the ex vivo response was the
strongest determinant of clinical outcome.
So Alex and company at ex vivo have been working with both of us, with all of our
data sets, to come up with a novel concept of pharma type.
Now, the traditional approach in this ex vivo functional world that all of us have
always been working from has been, you have a drug of interest or a drug regimen of
interest, test that regimen ex vivo. If it works, treat the patient.
If it doesn't, don't treat the patient. Makes a lot of sense, obviously.
But the pharma type concept takes it a step further and asks, are there additional
drugs from the ex vivo profile that even if the patient's not being treated
with those drugs, might be useful in predicting whether the patient responds to
that single regimen? And so the pharma type approach
aggregates a signature, an ex vivo drug response signature, to make
predictions about single therapeutic regimens.
And it looks to be very promising. There are two use cases that ex vivo have
developed, one for predicting the venetoclax hypomethylating agent frontline for
AML, and another for predicting FLT3 inhibitor response in AML, which is
one of the now approved regimens for FLT3 mutant AML.
But these ex vivo signatures
are potentially capturing a FLT3 wild-type population
who would still benefit from these FLT3 inhibitors.
I'll just show you a little bit of the data from analysis of the OHSU
and the FIM data sets in which this aggregated drug
response performs better than just looking at venetoclax response
and shows a very
high level of accuracy of predicting which patients will respond, which will be
refractory.Collectively between the two datasets,
ex vivo has now looked at a cohort of over 100
AML patients who are both newly diagnosed and in
a relapsed refractory setting.
And the
prediction accuracy for ven-HMA treatment is
approaching 100% in the newly diagnosed setting and a little over
90% in the relapsed refractory setting, substantially better than
looking at just venetoclax alone, which is the 87%, 89%.
And interestingly, what they've found is that looking at this aggregated drug
response profile works differently in the newly diagnosed versus relapsed
refractory settings, where there are false negatives that are apparent in the
newly diagnosed setting that are corrected by the pharma type, and false
positives in the relapsed refractory setting that are corrected.
So the next steps here, we're very excited about working with ex vivo to
conduct some large observational trials initially, then leading to,
similar to the question of Dr. Tuveson, interventional trials to prospectively
validate the work.
Okay, in my last couple of minutes, I just want to talk about the single-cell
sequencing-based readouts. And so we've had the idea of
taking these primary specimens, conducting our ex vivo drug responses, but then
rather than using a plate-based assay, can we harness the power of single-cell
sequencing to give us better granularity and allow us to look at very
nuanced populations of cells, understand how they're responding, not responding,
and what we might do about that? So we've
done this on about 10 samples now. We've taken these samples, treated them with a
handful of drugs, about maybe 10 drug conditions,
hashtagged each of those drug treatment conditions, performed a surface
labeling CITE-seq with about 163 antibodies, put
it all together onto a chromium, and
done single-cell analysis from which we can then look at single-cell populations,
how they're responding, not responding.
The data look very compelling. Even though it's early, they look very interesting.
So this is an example from one patient that we treated with about six
different single-agent drug combinations.
On the left is the vehicle. So this shows you just sort of what were the basal
characteristics of this tumor, which was comprised of these more
committed cells, several types of monocyte-like cells, as well as some
dendritic cell-like cells. When we expose this sample to
venetoclax, the BCL-2 inhibitor over on the right, we can see dramatic shifts.
This is after just 16 hours of venetoclax exposure.
We see that nearly all of those dendritic-like cells are eliminated, but the
monocyte-like populations persist.
When we treat with a FLT3 inhibitor, gilteritinib, we see almost the opposite.
The dendritic cells are not touched.
The monocyte-like cells are more eliminated.
The combination of venetoclax gilteritinib looks extremely promising.
It eliminates almost all the tumor cells.
The T cells and NK cells are spared, but there is
this one population of CD14-like monocytes that persists.
It persists all of the therapies. So this
would predict that the CD14 monocyte-like population is the drug-resistant
population that's going to be problematic.
In my last minute, the question that everyone in this field always gets, is this
predictive of clinical outcome? Important question.
So I
only have n of one to tell you about this. It's early.
We haven't had the opportunity to have very many patients that we've done this on
come back and collect a longitudinal sample.
But we've had one where the patient was treated with ven/aza over eight months.
We had samples pre and post, for which we did the ex vivo single cell.
And what we see is that ex vivo, the
ven/aza treatment,
nearly identically mirrored what was seen at that post-treatment, eight months
after therapy, in terms of the cell distributions.
And to put that into these stacked bar charts, you can see on the left is the
pre-treatment sample, the vehicle versus the ex vivo, where we can see a dramatic
persistence of those CD14 monocytes, elimination of the multipotent
progenitor cells, or near elimination.
That's exactly what happened clinically.
You can see on the right are the post-treatment samples where the vehicle lines up
almost completely with that 16 hour.
So 16 hours of ex vivo treatment, we're able to predict what happened over
eight months of therapy in this sample.
N of one, we have to do more of it, obviously. So I'm out of time.
I would just like to conclude by saying that I think the time is ripe
for a change of sentiment in terms of functional precision medicine
to begin to get these trials that have been predicted based on large ex
vivo datasets into patients, into clinical trials, and to use these
types of technologies as companion diagnostics.
Thank you.
I would just like to thank all the people that did this work, who are listed on
this slide. Could not have done it without all the contributions of all the people
listed on this slide, as well as for the Beat AML,
over 100 collaborators and of course, all of the patients and families.
I'm happy to take any questions.
Are there any questions from the audience?
Can you hear me?
Yes.
I have a question.
Yep.
Really beautiful talk.
Can you tell us what data exactly goes into the pharma type prediction
score? Is this just transcriptomics, or are you also doing like a
multi-integrator approach to predict the score?
Yeah. The pharma type is purely based on ex vivo responses.
So it's a panel of drugs that are tested ex vivo on the sample,
and then it's a
composite view of multiple of those drugs to predict the clinical
response of a single drug.
I see. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Nicholas Crown, Mobius Bio. Thanks. Beautiful talk.
Have you looked at the leukemia reinitiation potential of the leftover
monocytic cells?
That has been done. We have not done it, but it has been done.
Some beautiful work out of Colorado, Craig Jordan, Dan Pe'er, Xinxin Pei,
and yes, they've shown that there are monocyte-like LSCs,
is what they've termed them, and they do have the potential to engraft into PDX
models, et cetera. So yes, that has absolutely been demonstrated.
But to my understanding, sorry for following up here,
only in a subset of patient, and there are monocytic M4, M5-like
patients who do respond-
Mm.
And potentially also relapse in a more immature-
State afterwards.
Yes. So I didn't have time to get into it, but monocyte-like
cells is one mechanism of resistance of HMA.
It's not the only one, for sure. There are other mechanisms. P53 is a mechanism.
And it does appear there's some very recent papers that we've put out looking at
large clinical cohorts, where it appears that this monocyte-like relationship
is conditional on genetics. So in most genetic subsets, it is true the
monocyte-like are resistant. There are two where it's not, which is NPM1 and
P53, and those are important subsets.
So it is more complex than just cell state. Absolutely.
Thank you.
Yep.
All right.
Thank you.
I guess okay. Thank you.
You want me to moderate this?
Pardon?
You want me to moderate your talks please?
Okay.
All
right.
Delighted
to introduce Dr. Pier Paolo Claudio from University of Mississippi Medical
Center,
who's been doing some really interesting work with ChemoID and this whole
functional precision medicine platform.
Looking forward to hearing his talk, "Functional Precision Oncology: Predicting
Therapeutic Response Using Patient Tumor Models."
Thank you. Thank you,
Jeffrey.
So those are my disclosures.
The last one is probably relevant to this talk.
So, as we said earlier, clearly pathology is
evolving, and with that, also how we guide the treatment options.
Okay? So the generation one histopathology,
we are still using it. Is the main core of
how we diagnose what type of cancer, and the
characteristics such as histology, tumor grade, stage,
mitotic rate, and invasion guide actually
therapy.
Generation two, when molecular pathology
came online, treatment started to be guided
through DNA mutational analysis, and we saw
over time that unfortunately,
not all patients we can recognize actionable
mutations. Only 30, 40%, and out of this, only 10,
15% actually are this mutation linked to
molecular-targeted drugs. So in other words, patients
have no recommended molecular targets for 80,
90% of them,
and that's a limitation.
So generation three is the functional pathology in which
treatment is guided by functional precision
medicine assays, as we have heard from
these
speakers before,
and you will probably hear also from me, I hope to convey that to
you.
Why we do this? We do this because cancer is unique,
because each patient is unique, and because their response is
unique to therapy,
and only one in four patients actually respond to any
given chemotherapy. We don't know really which drugs they
will respond. We know that we have, in clinical trials,
the so-called average responders are in
the middle of the curve. We have high responders, and
unfortunately, we have non-responders.
However, everybody is
having those nasty side effects that nobody wants to have.
So it's important to pinpoint the right drug at the right moment for each
unique patient.
Now, we are at the ACR, and I wanted to tell
you that in 2006, actually, the
ACR defined cancer stem cells, which are cells
within a tumor that possess this capacity to self-renew,
to cause heterogeneous lineages of cancer that comprise
the tumor. They've been called in several manners, cancer stem cells, tumor
initiating cells, drug-tolerant persistent cells, and they are
all responsible of all these processes that bring tumors
from being an in situ tumor to
becoming bigger and to
metastasize. So tumor angiogenesis, tumor growth, tumor invasion,
tumor metastasis, all driven by these cells.
And cancer stem cells learn how to survive
treatments, okay? Making themself even more resistant treatment
after treatment. They are highly resistant to chemo and radiation therapy,
and that's what is important, because they act as a
repair kit following suboptimal chemotherapy, and they cause
tumor recurrence.
We actually have perfected a
methodology to grow, rapidly, cancer stem cells
using bioreactors, and we have increased their
number from 1% to
several fold increase, like 26,
27% increase from a biopsy.
And you can see here how, in blue, we
depict those cells from, in this case, ovarian cancer,
that are marking for CD44, CD24,
CD117, CD184. In blue, you can
see the enrichment of cells that we are actually testing.
Those are the cells in the cancer stem cell...
a portion of our test and the red ones are the
ones that are the so-called bulk of tumor, that are negative to those
markers. And if you take those cells and you actually
inject them, whether you are magnetically sorting them for
individual markers like CD44, 17, CD133,
and you inject only 100 cells in limiting dilution
in nude mice, you will form tumors.
Okay? Because those are initiating, tumor-initiating cells.
And if you take the same number of cells grown with the
bioreactor, we will form very large tumors because we are actually
enriching all of those cells
that are immature. So what is the idea that we have
been proposing is that what we have been seeing in
normal therapy,
in standard of care, non-targeted by a
test, such
precision medicine test,
here are depicted in yellow bulk
of tumor cells and in red, the cancer stem cells, which are the
minority. So in normal therapy, what happens
is that we see the tumor shrinking because we are targeting the bulk of
tumor. Those
carpet bombing chemotherapies that have
been
derived over 50 years ago, that's what they target,
cells that divide. And so they spare those resting
cells that are the cancer stem cells.
And the cancer stem cells acting as a repair kit will
grow back the tumor. Okay? So the idea
is to tailor therapy toward both the bulk of tumor
and the cancer stem cells so that we can suck the oxygen out from
those tumors and eliminating the repair kit.
In other words, the tumor will not be able to recur,
or we will have a prolonged response.
So from a cancer patient, a live tumor biopsy comes to the
laboratory. The bulk of tumor cells are grown from that.
The cancer stem cells in within seven days are grown.
And then the chemotherapies are applied in a
panel of several drugs, and not only single drugs,
but also combination drugs. And then post analysis,
is done a post-treatment analysis of both population.
And the chemo ID result is given as a upper portion in which we are
showing the bulk of tumor resistance or
sensitivity to the chemotherapies and the bottom portion, that is the
cancer stem cells. This is conveyed to the oncologist, the oncologist tailors
therapy, and hopefully, the patient has a good
outcome, which we'll show
you later. So,
the biopsy is shipped through a biopsy transportation
kit that within
36 hours at room temperature,
if it reaches within 36 hours, we are still able to do the
test. And ideally, we heard
earlier that
18 gauge core,
many of those, and we also have set up that we need four of those
or
less if the core is bigger or ideally 12 to 15
millimeters. And the test actually is 14 to 21
days to test result. We can start also from ascites, which
bring the number of days to seven.
So of course, we have done several studies, several
clinical studies that brought us and informed
the two randomized prospective clinical trials we have
conducted. One is on recurrent platinum-resistant ovarian
cancer, and the other one is on recurrent
glioblastoma.
We'll talk about first the recurrent glioblastoma.
Those are all the participating sites.
I want to give a big kudos to all the doctors that participated
to this trial because they helped us greatly advance functional
precision medicine. And this was
published in 2023 in Cell Reports Medicine.
And the study schema for this trial was
to enroll recurrent Grade 4
gliomas.
And those patients had a biopsy taken or a
resection, and they all received a chemo
ID assay. Then they were randomized in a standard
of care arm, in which the physician was actually picking
one of those drugs or combination to treat the
patient, or in the other arm, in which the treatment was
guided by the test result. The
endpoint
for this trial was overall survival and then secondary endpoints of
PFS.
And what I want to show you here are
two
of the
trial's test reports. You can see that
you may have several options in the bulk, but you may have one or
two options in the cancer stem cell portion.
And if you don't do the test, you will never know which one is actual, the
combination to give or the drug to give to
this patient in particular. So the results
are in the primary endpoint. We observed a benefit of
4.5 months between the two arms,
in favor of the chemo ID guided therapy arm.
And the median overall survival for patients treated in the
chemo ID group was 12 months,
and instead 7.5 months in the physician choice group.
I want to remind you all that Temodar, that is used as
a chemotherapy radio sensitizer that in
combination with radiation therapy and surgery,
prolonged only for two months basically, 2.2 months
became standard of care. We have here a 4.5 months difference
just by guiding standard of care treatment in the second
lineAnd here I'm
going to show you a time lapse of patient survival from
Physician Choice Arm and ChemoID Guided.
I want you to focus on this upper right
part of the
diagram in which you're going to see the big difference of patients
treated with ChemoID versus
standard of care. You see that those patients are dying much faster
than the ChemoID Guided until 18 months.
Okay?
So it's a huge difference, and that was very comforting for us because we
knew we were doing the right thing.
If we look at their median PFS, we can see that there
is a benefit of 3.2 months in median PFS in
the ChemoID therapy guided group with a median
PFS that was 6.5 months in the ChemoID guided versus
3.3 months in the Physician Choice group.
Of course, all of this data is statistically
supported.
And now I'm going to shift to the
platinum-resistant ovarian cancer,
recurrent ovarian cancer study. Those are all, again, the
participating sites all over the United States, and
a big kudos to those physicians who helped us
recruit those patients
and enroll them. This was
published in 2025 in
MPJ Precision Oncology,
and again, the schema is very
similar to the previous one in which, in this
case, we enrolled the recurrent platinum-resistant ovarian
cancer participants with less or equal to
five prior treatments, including at least
one platinum. Means those patients are very far
along their disease.
And all of the patients provided a sample that was
confirmed for diagnosis, and the ChemoID
assay was performed. Then they were randomized to
a standard of care arm, and the treatment was blinded to
test results. And in
the other arm, the ChemoID guided treatment was guided.
All patients received one of those treatments,
and whether they were in arm one or arm two, just like the
other trial.
And in this case, the primary endpoint was overall response rate by
resist criteria, so on CT scans and MRIs.
Secondary endpoint was PFS and durational response
in CA 125 levels.
Again, here you can see how different are patients.
Here on the left, you have a patient who has lots of
good drugs that can be treated with.
And here will be easier for a physician to treat the patient with
the right drug, even in the absence of the test.
Let's think about the patient on the right.
Patient on the right has only one good drug for the bulk of tumor and
basically close to nothing because it's about
52%, and that's it. And then after that, you get less than
50% cell kill. So the test here would be very
good to exclude the drugs not to give to the patient because we are
going to just cause harm and no benefit.
So here is the primary endpoint for those patients.
In the physician choice, we had a 5%
objective response rate, which means patients with manifesting
a clinical response of complete
response and/or partial response.
And instead, for the ChemoID arm,
55% of patients had a
clinical response that was
beneficial to them. And you can see here the
CT scans of those patients. And if we look at
clinical benefit by adding stable disease
to complete response and partial response, the benefit goes up to
85% versus 24%. So the difference is so
large that the P value is so minuscule with the seven zeros in
front of a five.
The PFS also was greatly
distant. The two arms, they were greatly distant with a
three months PFS in the physician choice
arm. So patients treated with standard of care had only three
months before they progressed. And instead, in the ChemoID guided group,
11 months. This was statistically supported, okay, with a
log rank of 0001.
Now, if we look at the tumor burden change in each of the
groups, on the left you have physician choice, on the right you have ChemoID
guided. You have most of the patients treated in the
physician choice who manifested actually progressive disease here in
purple. And you have very few that have stable disease here
in blue. And you have only one that had a partial response in
orange and only one that had a complete response in gray.
Mirroring image on the other group in which
most of the patient had either stable disease or complete response or
partial response. And we're going to go more in details, and I'm going to try to
explain to you why these things happened.
So for example, this particular patient who had a progressive disease
was treated with doxorubicin.
Retrospectively, because this is physician choice, they were treated
blindly, retrospectively, we could see that actually both
bulk of tumor or cancer stem cells
were actually not killed at all by doxorubicin.
The doctor didn't know that. However, you have here another
patient who has been treated with the same drug,
doxorubicin. In this case, it's good
for bothBulk of tumor and cancer stem
cells, and had a complete response
blindly. The doctor didn't know.
But this patient had only a single drug to be treated with.
Nothing else worked. The doctor lucked out, the patient lucked out.
Now let's look at the chemo ID group, because we had also some patients
who actually had a
progressive disease. And why?
So in this case, paclitaxel carboplatin
is the drug combination. This patient was
nonsensitive for the cancer stem cells and very,
very moderately sensitive for the bulk of tumor.
And you can see here, this patient had an option only for the bulk of
tumor, which is here. Okay. And basically, this was
35% cell kill. And later on, we'll talk about what the
cutoff is for having a good
response. So 35% is not enough. The patient had a
progressive disease.
This other patient here instead, with the same
doublet of drugs, paclitaxel carboplatin, extremely
sensitive to it, had a complete response.
Again, telling the story that guiding chemotherapy with a functional
assay helps.
And you can see here the patient, single therapy that was
actually sensitive for this patient, and the doctor could have
not known which drug would be sensitive to unless had
this test in hands.
And you can see here with the cutoff here,
in the chemo ID guided, all the patients that are in green had a
complete response and/or partial response, and the
cutoff is 50% cell kill for cancer stem cells and
50% cell kill for bulk of tumor. If the patient
was treated with drugs over 50% for both
categories of
cells explored, they would have a good response, and they did.
And mirroring image instead, the physician choice standard
of care.
So another thing I want to convey to you is that a surrogate
marker often is CA 125, and
CA 125 here, what has been shown is that how
if the change between baseline and
second or third
visit of the patient it goes down rapidly,
the durational sort of response is great, and
that also means that the patient is responding.
So the slope in the chemo ID guided group
was much more pronounced than the patients treated in the
physician choice. ECOG status, number of
platinum treatments, age, and
race, this was not associated with response.
I want to also let you know that this test has
been granted breakthrough device designation by the FDA
last year for treating
brain tumors, and we are also applying right now for ovarian
cancer.
And I would like to thank all the patients, their family,
the principal investigator, the coordinators, the chemo ID
laboratory at Cabell Huntington Hospital in West Virginia, all the
doctors that have participated, the prior and
current Claudio laboratory
students and personnel,
and I'm here to answer all your questions. Thank you.
Thank you for an outstanding presentation. Open for questions. Over there.
Thank you so much for your perfect presentation.
Sure.
My concern is when you mentioned about the cancer stem cell,
it doesn't matter what we want to put the name on it or
tumor-initiating population, the idea is a lot
changed since 2006 until 2026. We're
past the 20 years right now. I'm not going to argue about this part,
but I think we are talking about the personalized
medicine, and we want to bring to the attention of the field
that we should
recalculate which way or what's the time or what type of the
drug we want to apply to the patient in benefit or management of the patient.
But when you mentioned that about the cancer stem cell, as a huge
field, we have to talk about the
macro environments, what type of the stage, what type of the
theory we want to apply
such a chemotherapy to such a case of the patient.
My question would be, what do you think about the personalized medicine,
and how we able to apply your
idea to the general oncology field, and
how patient can benefit out of this idea? That's it.
So it's a very general question and takes into account that there are
several tests that are coming online which are
also like organoids,
what also Jeffrey showed that see other
aspects in the liquid tumors. But
there are more and more tests that are coming online.
This is not going to be the only one.
This has been incidentally
the first one that has been going through randomized
clinical trials, and there are several tests that
will reach that point,
and this is the exact question. How much data do we need to
convince the oncologists? Because
treating oncologists are always set with their mind in
judging this like the Sanger
sequencing, and today, we are actually adopting
genome byte sequencing,
which is not done with that technology, and these are not done with
those technologies that the very first
sensitivities assays, which I like to call
vulnerability assays-... are okay today.
So it'll take a while, I think, to convince them. It'll take more studies.
I hope that more laboratories will prove their point
using different platforms.
Our platform, we know has been proven clinically, and it works even if
we don't have or don't take into account the, as you
said, the tumor microenvironment, which I understand.
But although it's probably more simple, but
it gave clinical
applicable answers
to treat patients which were validated by the clinical
trials.
Thank you.
Let's go to the middle.
Thank you for the presentation. As you know, most of the
cancer stem cell trial have
not really expected any clinical
benefit for the past 20 years, right?
So I'm very happy you have something that is, let's say,
give
improvement of the survival. So my question is,
how did you monitor? You said that the percentage of the stem cells.
How did you monitor the stem cells?
Because it's such a nonspecific marker.
So how do you know those are really-- How do you monitor this process-
So-
... you are targeting the right thing?
So basically, we have conducted several studies, not only of
immunophenotyping them,
okay? And knowing which
each one of those pathologists with cancers,
histopathology, we were growing, which markers they were
expressing. But also we have injected them in limiting
dilution in animals to show that those cells
that were cultured in the bioreactor were actually
tumor-initiating cells. This is the gold standard, sir.
Well, we'll get to discuss it.
Thank you.
Over on the far side.
Yes. I think this is a very promising approach-
Thank you
... to treat the patient. I see the light there.
I have two questions.
Yes.
First question here is,
I'm not sure how many tumor tissue you got.
You need the essential cells become bulk cells, and
separate the stem cells that you do two
bioreactor assay, right?
So, yeah.
So, well, each patient actually went through the same process,
which I can show you if I may.
Here you can see the biopsy taken as a fresh sterile sample,
then we generate the primary cell line,
and within seven days, we enrich the cancer stem cells,
then we treat them separately, and then we report the
assay as a continuous from less than 10% to 100% cell kill.
Does that address the question?
So you enrich the cells by culturing?
Correct. In seven days.
All right.
Because of the bioreactor.
It's a culturing condition. They coach the resting cell to
actually divide,
maintaining their stemness.
So my second question is quick. Have you tried using perfusion
to do those kind of testings? Because-
Like a microchip?
No, perfusion cells.
No, we haven't.
Looks like we have three more questions. Let's go over here first.
Hi, I'm Brian Rubin from the Cleveland Clinic.
I'm a pathologist, and I run actually a fairly large laboratory.
Yes sir.
And so these were beautiful talks, and I love the functional medicine
approach. But I'm sitting here thinking, is there a pathway
back to the pathology and lab, a simple approach
like maybe transcriptomics, a simple transcriptional profile,
immunohistochemical studies that you guys see?
Because I think the problem of functional approach is unless we get really,
really good at them, and I was really impressed with the last talk and how-
Thank you
... good you've gotten,
they're going to be a little bit cumbersome shipping the tumors
at scale for the entire world. These are going to be problems, and
so do you guys see a pathway back to the lab, or are we going
to be doing functional approaches, and that's just going to be the approach
that's most informative for treatment?
That's a fantastic question. Thank you so much because it gives me the opportunity
to talk about also shipping samples.
So we are working also with institutions abroad.
And when I mean abroad, I mean either Europe or India.
And we are receiving samples that arrive to the laboratory viable because
we have perfected a manner of shipping them at room
temperature, and the cells are actually able to survive
that, and we are able to do it. So as far as
scaling, of course, you need a bigger laboratory,
many more people to work in because of course, it's a little
labor-intensive in making the cell line.
But again, within 7 to 14
days, the report is out, so it's possible.
It's a possibility. And it is highly reproducible, the test.
We work in a CLIA and CAP-accredited environment,
and we have provided all the data of
QC and QA, so quality controls that
we do every week to the samples
before any patient is tested in the laboratory.
We provided all this. They were very happy for the reproducibility
of the test, and that's why they granted the BDD.
Okay. I can say in Heme, we had the same experience.
These assays are compatible with shipped samples as long as it's fast, overnight,
two days is absolutely compatible.
Let's go to the middle and then back over.
Following Dr. Rubin, another pathologist, Sunil Badve from Emory.
Hi.
Quick question. What are the insights that you have gained from the
resistant tumors? Or have you been able to figure out why
resistance develop? Because clearly you're targeting the CSCs,
so in spite of that, these tumors seem to develop resistance.
Any insights would be greatly valuable.
Yeah, of course. More studies need to be done to do that.
And lucky us, we asked the patients to provide a
release so that we have saved the cell lines that were
remaining
after the test that
we had leftover cells. We bank them, and we
continue to study them. And one of the students, my PhD student, actually,
is working right on this.
Thank you.
Final question.
Sorry, I'll be a bit of a rock star here.
Thank you so much for the fantastic talks.
Thank you.
I can't wait to see the ones you'll be giving 10 years from now when this is
mainstream for everyone. So two quick questions.
The first one is, are you at all thinking about how you can translate the
predictive power of these more late-stage testing for clinical positioning and
early stages of discovery for high throughput drug design and
screening?
Is that something that you're working on?
And then the second is, how are you thinking about other modalities, and have there
been any advancements in application of these technologies for immunotherapy
development, for example?
Yeah. So that's another great question. Thank you.
So first of all,
these technologies can be definitely coupled with
genomic analysis and AI.
Okay? That would be the future. Okay, that's the first step
we are doing. I envision that this will end up with
AI helping
all of it and
combining data from genomic analysis with functional precision
medicine. That is really the future.
Now, as far as the first part of the question, of course, any of
those tests can be used for
screening drugs and finding new drugs, and in
particular, finding drugs maybe that can target
those more resistant cancer stem cells, which is what we all aim
at.
Thank you.
Oh, one more.
Final, final question.
Just a quick clarifying question.
Yes.
When you looked at the panels, and you were demonstrating so
convincingly that resistance was shown in either the
physicians group or the sensitivity in the assay,
I only saw a few drugs being tested per patient.
Did you not test the whole panel?
All of it. All of it was tested in each patient.
What in the-
But most of the fields are empty.
Yeah. Okay. So in the diagram you saw,
we put only the
sensitive drugs or the resistant drug marked by an
X by what drug was actually used for the patient,
showing you that the drug that was used was actually not
an optimal drug or was an optimal drug.
Then I showed you a couple of those
test results to show you the entire panel.
Each patient was screened for all the entire panel.
But maybe for one patient, we found a very good
drug or no drugs, and if it was in the physician choice,
not knowing which one was the good drug, they picked any drug, and
incidentally, was not a good drug, either.
But most fields, as far as I recall, were actually empty,
most
squares. That was kind of-
Okay. Maybe I'm not explaining
...
was surprising.
In that diagram, we were marking
whether the drug that was used was a good drug
or a suboptimal drug. That's all was to it. And with an X.
Okay? And that's all it was there. Okay? It's not that it was empty.
We were not reporting. It would've been too busy.
I just showed you then later on the actual test report to show you
that everything was screened. Every patient was screened.
Yeah. Very wonderful presentation. Very short question.
Yes.
Have you tried to isolate these cells from patient-derived
xenograft model? I'm asking that from a drug developer's perspective.
If we could look at different payloads for ADCs, how they affect
different populations-
So you-
... in the PDX models
... so you are saying instead of starting from a
patient sample directly, a biopsy, but starting from
a patient sample that was injected
in,
grown, so a PDX, basically. Yes.
Yes.
Grown in mice. At the very
beginning, we were doing this testing, actually.
We were doing this testing of putting the cells isolated back and
forth in mice and then re-isolating and doing these whole things. Yes.
So we were able to do cell lines of those. Yeah.
Okay. Thanks.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you, everybody.
I guess that this concludes the session.